today hundreds of cyclists came out to
honor the five lives lost in a horrific
crash last year the memorial bicycle
ride was held to bring awareness and
encourage safety on the roads victoria
saha spoke with those who were
courageous enough to continue riding
a goal every single rider here wants to
accomplish ghost bikes are placed at the
scene of where a bicyclist lost their
life tragically because of a driver put
the phone down
you know not drive impaired and just
really be courteous to other road users
on saturday founder of ghost bikes of
las vegas pat treachel brought a white
ghost bike with five seats honoring the
five lives lost in a grizzly crash
december 10th of 2020 it was pretty much
the 911 of the las vegas cycling
community
i personally knew all five of them a
truck driver was high on methamphetamine
when he swerved and hit the group of
cyclists on the u.s 95 near searchlight
i remember meeting just like this
fantastic morning everything was nice
michael anderson was part of that
cycling group on that fateful day i look
down the road a little bit further and i
see a pile of other riders
oh my god he says it took him about a
month to get the courage to ride again
but the trauma remained sometimes i have
to pull over on the side of the road
because i think
i am going to get smashed but that fear
didn't stop bicyclists from riding down
the strip saturday honoring those five
lives with every pedal forward victoria
saha live local now